let's start again with a point let's
call that point point a and what i'm
curious about is all of the points on my
screen right over here that are exactly
two centimeters away from a so two
centimeters on my screen is about is
about that far so clearly if i started a
and i go two centimeters in that
direction this point right over there is
two centimeters from a if i call that
point point b then i could say
line segment a b is two centimeters the
length is two centimeters remember this
would refer this would refer to the
actual line segment i could say this
looks nice but if i talk about its
length i would get rid of that line on
top and i would just say a b is equal to
two if i wanted to put units i could say
two centimeters but i'm not curious just
about b i want to think about all the
points the set of all of the points that
are exactly two centimeters away from a
so i could go two centimeters in the
other direction
maybe get to point c right over here so
ac is also going to be equal to two
centimeters but i could go two
centimeters in any direction and so if i
find the set of all of the points that
are exactly two centimeters away from a
i will get a very familiar familiar
looking shape like this and i'm trying
to draw it freehand so i would get a
shape that looks like this and actually
let me draw it in i don't want to make
you think it's only the points where
there's white it's all of these points
right over here i want to draw a dashed
line over there maybe i should just let
me clear out all of these and i'll just
draw a solid line
so this it could look something like
that
my best attempt
and this set of all of the points that
are exactly two centimeters away from a
this is a circle as i'm sure you are
already familiar with but that is the
formal definition the set of all points
that are a fixed distance or that have a
fixed distance from a that are given
distance from a if i said the set of all
points that are three centimeters from a
it might look something like this
it might look something like that that
would give us another circle
it would give us another circle i think
you get the general idea now what i want
to do in this video is introduce
ourselves into some of the concepts and
words that we use when dealing with
circles so let me get rid of that three
centimeter circle so first of all let's
think about
this distance this distance or or one of
these line segments that join a which we
would call the center of the circle
so we'll call a the center of the circle
and it makes sense just from the way we
use the word center in everyday life
what i want to do is think about what
line segment a b is so a b a b connects
the center and it connects a point on
the circle itself remember the circle
itself is all the points that are equal
distance from the center so a b any
point any line segment i should say that
connects the center to a point on the
circle we would call a radius
is a
radius
and so the length of the radius a b over
here is equal to two centimeters and
you're probably already familiar with
the word radius but i'm just being a
little bit more formal and what's
interesting about geometry at least when
you start learning it at the high school
level is it's probably the first class
where you're introduced into a slightly
more formal mathematics where we're a
little bit more careful about giving our
definitions and then building on those
definitions to come up with interesting
results and proving to ourselves that we
definitely know what we think we know
and so that's why we're being a little
bit more careful with our language over
here so a b is our radius line segment a
b and so is line segment let me draw
another
so let me put another point on here
let's say this is x so line segment ax
is also a radius
line segment ax is also a radius is also
a
radius now you can also have other forms
of lines and line segments that interact
in interesting ways with this circle
so you could have a line that just
intersects that circle at exactly one
point so let's call that point right
over there and let's call that d and
let's say you have a line let's say you
have a line and the only point on the
circle that
the only point in the set of all the
points that are equal distant from a the
only point on that circle that is also
on that line is point d and we could
call that line let's call that line l so
sometimes you'll see lines specified by
some of the points on them so for
example if i had another point right
over here called e we could call this
line
line d e
or we could just put a little a little
script letter here with an l and say
this is line l but this line that only
has one point in common with our circle
we call this a tangent line so line l is
a tangent it is tangent
tangent to the circle so let me write it
this way line l
line l
is tangent
and you normally wouldn't write it in
caps like this i'm just doing that for
emphasis is tangent to
instead of writing the circle centered
at a you'll sometimes see this notation
to
the circle centered at a so this tells
us that this is the circle we're talking
about because who knows maybe we had
another circle over here that is
centered at m
another circle so we have to specify
it's not tangent to that one is tangent
to this one so this circle with a dot in
the middle tells we're talking about a
circle and this is a circle centered at
point a i want to be very clear point a
is not on the circle point a is the
center of the circle the points on the
circle are the points equal distant from
point a
now
l is tangent because it only intersects
the circle on one point you could just
as easily imagine a line you could
imagine a line that intersects the
circle at two points
so we could call maybe this is f and
this is g
you could call that line f g so we could
write like this
line f g and this line that intersects
at two points we call this a secant
of circle a
is
a secant
it is a secant line to this circle right
over here because it intersects it in
two points now if fg was just a segment
if it didn't keep on going forever like
lines like to do if we only spoke about
this line segment let me do this in a
new color if we only spoke about this
line segment between
f and g and not thinking about going on
forever then all of a sudden we have a
line segment which we would specify
there
and we would call this a chord of the
circle
is a chord
a chord of
circle a it starts at a point on the
circle a point that is
exactly in this case two centimeters
away and then it finishes at a point on
the circle so it connects two points on
the circle now you can have chords like
this and you can also have a chord as
you can imagine a chord that actually
goes through the center of the circle so
let's say call this point
let's call this point h and you have a
straight line connecting f
to h through a so that's about as
straight as i could draw it so if you
have a chord like that so if you have
a chord like this that contains the
actual center of the circle of course it
goes from one point on the circle to
another point of circle and it goes
through the center of the circle we call
that a diameter of a
is
a
diameter
is a diameter
of
circle a and you've probably seen this
in
in in tons of problems before when we
were not talking about geometry as
formally but the diameter is made up of
exactly two radiuses we know
we already know that a radius connects a
point to the center so you have one
radius right over here that connects f
and h
sorry f and a that's one radius and then
you have another radius connecting a and
h the center to a point on the circle so
a diameter is made up of these two
radiuses or radii i should call i think
that's the plural for radius and so the
length of a diameter is going to be
twice the length of a radius so we could
say
we could say the length of the diameter
so the length of fh and once again i
don't put the line on top of it when i'm
just talking about the length is going
to be equal to fa the length of
segment fa
plus the length of segment
plus the length of segment ah now
there's last there's one last thing i
want to talk about when we're dealing
with circles and that's the idea of an
arc so we can also we also have the
parts of the circle itself so let me
draw another circle over here let's
center this circle right over here at b
and i'm going to find some points all
the points that are a given distance
from b so it has some radius i'm not
going to specify it right over here and
let me pick some random points on this
circle so let's call this let's call
this i don't know what let's call that j
let's call that k
let's call this let's call that s let's
call this t
let's call this u right over here and i
know it doesn't look that centered let
me try to center b a little bit better
let me erase that and put b a little bit
closer to the center of the circle
so that's my best shot so let's put b
right over there
now one interesting thing is what do you
call the length of the circle that goes
between two points so what would you
call what would you call let me get a
good color here what would you call this
well you could imagine in everyday
language we would call something that
looks like that an arc and we would also
call that an arc in geometry to specify
this arc we would call this we would
call this we would say jk the two
endpoints of the arc the two points on
the circle that are the end points of
the arc and you use a little notation
like that so you put a little a little
curve on top instead of a straight line
now you can also have another arc that
connects j and k this is the minor arc
it is the shortest way along the circle
to connect j and k but you could also go
the other way around you could also have
this thing that goes all the way around
the circle
and we would call that the major arc and
normally when you specify a major arc
just to show that you're going kind of
the long way around the way that you you
know it's not the shortest way to get
between j and k you'll often specify
another point that you're going through
so for example this major arc we could
specify we started j we went through we
could have said u t or s but i'll put t
right over there we went through t and
then we went all the way to k
and so this specifies the major arc and
this thing could have been the same
thing as if i wrote j uk
that these are specifying the same thing
or j
s k so there's multiple ways to specify
this major arc right over here but the
one thing i want to make clear is is
that the minor arc is the shortest
distance so this is the minor arc
minor arc and the longer distance around
is the major arc
is the
major arc and i'll leave you there and
maybe in the next few videos we'll start
playing with some of this notation a
little bit more